He came,
he saw he heckled over the weekend,
Patriot Front, a white supremacy group
that believes their ancestors
conquered America
and bequeathed it to them.
And no one else marched along the National
Mall in downtown Washington, D.C.
The police escorted members
throughout the city.
When one cyclist did this
where Wal-Mart only got a wife,
the only three of America
to come on him, you know, history for
you are the looters of your right to go
out and do this when you're being pushed.
South Africans have been cast
adrift and crushed
under four different types of pants
off the city of Brown.
Reclaim your Virginia
Well, let us bring in that gentleman
who was on the bike there, Joe
Flood, the writer and photographer
who heckled the group.
All right.
I have to ask you why this tactic?
Some people would come out
blasting them in a different way.
You were sort of joking, but,
you know, throwing barbs
Yeah, I've seen a lot of protests
and counter-protests in D.C.
and yeah, usually involves
people yelling back and forth.
So when I rolled up on the bike, I thought
and I would do something different.
And they looked so ridiculous
lined up in front of the Washington
Monument with the leader
giving this really boring speech.
It was just sort of the perfect moment
for me to roll up and start
hurling insults.
And I tried to be as personal
and direct as possible
because I think that gets to people more
than if you just start cursing at them.
Yeah.
At one point I heard on the video,
I heard you say, Oh, I got into your head
when you made a joke that one of them was
a General Custer's illegitimate child.
I do.
I do want to ask you, though,
about seeing this scene.
These are white nationalist
white supremacists
who believe this country belongs to them.
And only
and only two people of European descent.
What did you think
when you saw this group with
with no one else there to sort of say,
hey, this is not cool?
Well, they snuck into the city
without telling anyone
and they've done this before.
They sneak into the city.
No notice
except for the police, obviously.
And they march around for like 20 minutes
to leave to get their photo ops.
And that's why there's never been people
counter protesting them.
And so when I saw on Twitter
that they were marching around and
I was nearby, I decided that I had to go
and when I got there,
there was no one else yelling at them.
So I decided that I should yell at them.
Joe, did you hear anything from them?
Did they say anything back?
Was there any response Yeah.
When I heard the speaker,
the leader couldn't
memorize his speech
and he kept looking at his notes
and he kept pulling out his speech
to read it.
And then he put it back in
and start reading it again.
And I yelled at him like, boring.
Why can't you remember your
why can't you memorize your speech?
And he and and at one point,
I'm like, boring.
This is going on too long.
And he was like,
you should get comfortable.
This is going to be a while.
Joe Flood, thank you.
And thank you for making us giggle
about a very serious subject.
Thank you.